o lado pessoal que te falar que fiz
muitos meninos
a mais velha que eu tenho até uma mão
num leilão só hoje através de uma
notícia muito boa pra vocês não aquelas
tag que o caso do antigo não esperar há
pouco tempo e segue isolado ou se
espalharam existem tanto mas tanto meu
tempo tanto impacto que nós resolvemos
ir até o lá a apresentar a nossa idéia e
aceitar nós conseguimos saiu falei que
mais é no meio milhão dos lados grátis
pra todos vocês mas um milhão de
usuários já podem conferir os lados
daqui uma semana eu acho que aproveitei
milhão de dólares grave estou bem
contente porque eu também curto boys
lado e eu vou comer muito também para se
lembrarem se transferir por causa dos
meus lábios sobre deus que é o
perna-de-pau envolvem fazê la em tamanho
gigante mesmo muito grande mas já vão
brincar assim e estou muito empolgado
porque eu adoro perna de pau e vou fazer
um gigante que a sair muito bom eu acho
que tá bom eu acho eu vou citar aqui
algumas imagens 99 dólar ea explica
enquanto imagens e vamos pátria barata
[Música]
c
oi
[Música]
unidos vamos lutar agora nosso projeto
super de um lado o complemento como
queijos amarelos e chega primeiro mas
foi lá que eu vou tentar explicar aqui
em grande é um perna de pau lá eu é o
fato mais gosta é muito bom tem
chocolate morango
sou o paulo em razão muito grande agora
imaginem os dias 25 e 28
[Música]
olá vamos mais ouvir falar à nossa mesa
com papel de alumínio e depois vamos
colocar a nata do cinema e da plataforma
do pv paulo búfalo primeira fase então
vai ser por aqui
nesta data coisa e vamos fazer a
primeira chamada do nosso principal
depois o futuro paulo maio e depois
fazer as coisas de lado nada bebês que
ficam mais além de construir a fórmula 1
só a quantidade nem o meu deus meu deus
o meu espaço aqui dentro só vai
continuar investigando um caso que vamos
ter que eu acho que o brasil por cima e
das pesquisas com animais pessoal o gil
acabou por fazer não vai embora quando
chegou a fazer quatro em quatro dias já
está pronto a tempo muito mais peso e
estava plantas mas acho que é mesmo um
novo problema é que no frio é o o osso 4
vamos deixar um pouco
sim bem no frio não só eu comprei isso
mulheres não está tão bem quanto
internet palmas mais votado mas vamos
ver amanhã já poderá organizar
ninguém pode acusar nada mais de dez
minutos
já 45 abandonado e agora nos dias
estudos até os 10 minutos eo chocolate
ficar bons e vamos ver eu acho que vai
dar muita bola vai inventar não vai
ficar nada assim
[Música]
a curva da pedra preta e isso não vai
fazer eu pude provar um dia ser meio
milhão
[Música]